montois you 85 habitants une population
en hausse et rajeuni avec une vingtaine
d'enfants grâce au prix de l'immobilier
et à la proximité de dijon par
l'autoroute de nouveaux pauvres sont
arrivés notamment des couples venant de
lyon et c'est un village plus ou moins
deux dortoirs des habitants invisible
mairie fantôme pour l'ancien élu qu'il
ne voyait plus à quoi il pouvait servir
toutes les compétences à peu près toutes
ont été transférées à la communauté de
communes maintenir une mairie à un coût
de fonctionnement le cas de monthois you
environ dix mille euros c'est un peu du
gaspillage d'impôts le conseil municipal
est lui ayant emboîté le pas il a fallu
organiser des élections pas de candidat
les anciens de la commune tente donc
d'inciter les jeunes à se lancer
les gens ils ont peur de milan perd de
prendre cette responsabilité c'est pas
facile quand même pour des jeunes qui
travaillent
oui oui mais avec une bonne secrétaire
de mairie à bron secrétaire de mairie
tu sais ce que c'est que ça marche et on
va essayer de même de pousser certaines
personnes à faire bien sûr si ce n'est
déjà fait j'ai déjà rencontré des jeunes
et puis on en parle
une délégation temporaire gère les
affaires courantes mais la vie
municipale tourne au ralenti c'est ce
qui sera rappelée samedi matin lors
d'une réunion d'information presque une
cellule de crise
il n'y a rien de tel que les habitants
eux-mêmes pour gérer
leur commune décider de ce qui est bon
pour leur commune et des travaux à
réaliser et de tout ce qui suit un
nouveau scrutin est prévu les 3 et 10
mars si le même scénario devait se
reproduire montois you serait cette fois
pris v2 conseil municipal jusqu'aux
élections de l'an prochain